so okay not to be such a pessimist but
what would your life be like if all of
this ended tomorrow hmm
we were talking about that too I don't
know because it's like what was weird
cuz I went from fat cells right fat
cells so if you're not you don't know
what you don't live in LA you don't know
what fat cells is it's a sandwich a
sandwich shop and my brother I was
working the kitchen washing dishes dude
I was I was in it I was in the kitchen
yeah bagging meat washing dishes the
whole thing you know me and I went from
that to like machi touring and on this
bus and it's like you know from here to
here and then like if that ended its
like back you don't mean it's like
probably not like that but it'd be
probably hard to be a hard pill to
swallow
yeah yeah but you know what we talked
about though is because my brother have
mentioned to me that he might want to do
his own podcast yes well we're trying to
figure out another who would I do it
with maybe one paragraph behind if there
are two people in my mind that would
work for you cuz they've got to know who
you are
Yeah right I don't know like you don't
it's it's either - it's either Erik or I
Lonnie those are the only two in my mind
that would work yeah I think you a
Lonnie could do it yeah you and I Lonnie
argue very peculiar together that I
think that people would latch on to you
you're you're basically so compliment my
brother's eyes he doesn't know I do I
know I was just thinking cuz I just
talked to her sister and you know the
sisters husband and they they love Tiger
belly and you know they have friends
that subscribe to you you guys his thing
and they were so happy that you guys
were that Margaret Cho came on and we're
talking about like the Asian American
acting like the the casting aspect of
Hollywood and how you guys are a voice
for Asians and stuff like that feels
good yeah shoutout to IRA IRA and mark
shut outside yeah she's a really bright
girl Oh super smart anything under the
Sun you're a smart boy Eric and we get
excited we also get excited on this
podcast when we have other artists and
other people who doing [ __ ] following us
and vice versa and we've got a new
follower a couple of them this week tell
them who they are I have an email from
reading all right so yeah these are the
email and we'll explain it to Steve this
is an email from hey Bobby
thanks for sharing our YouTube video we
love your work and we want to work with
you Afton will write you a rap in
everything emojis face squinting the
struggle is real Afton Jillian Noah
throne okay do you know who Afton
jillian is know over that video I showed
you of that girl rapping bigger than
Dolly Parton which one is it remember
sonic box
she was rapping the struggle is weird
real you know remember in the car was
already in the car he goes dude you
gotta see this rap video man this girl
check it out yeah yeah she that was her
oh wow you got a lot of views on YouTube
well that's so weird because we talked
about it oh we talked about her oh I
didn't know that like yeah and listen to
me right now also this other guy spends
connelly I don't know if you listen you
were harsh on him I was a little hot but
let me say something right now if you're
listening both of you Spence Conley and
Afton Jillian and no other actor Afton's
Afton's boyfriend okay
I have seen your videos more than I've
seen any other video in the world yeah
so whether I know it's good
it's all good because it puts joy in my
heart it does yeah I enjoy it so um take
that for what it is you know um a lot of
Tiger Villa fans went on there and they
viewed some of the
and listen one of my favorite movies of
all time is trolls - noise - it's
literally one of my favorite movies of
all kind it is a little weird it's it's
considered to be a bad movie but it's
more entertaining than ro1 in my opinion
so it's like you know take it for what
it is you know I also on top of it also
it's like the other day on Twitter some
guy just added me do your stand-up is
awful you're not funny you know me you
get that a lot when you're putting
yourself out there yeah a lot of people
don't like me you know there's a lot of
people I love you oh that's true you
know there's a lot of people that love
you too Steve do you get hate mail Steve
a couple yeah one or two
like hater haters like they wrote an
essay - like you ruined a DVD essay
you're the worst [ __ ] your music is the
worst you know the mean stuff like that
but you know what do you when you read
it though you can't take it personal but
you do you take a personal what do you
want to find them yeah well I just kind
of wanted fantasies just finding out
where they live Stevie leaves on his
lawn right hey what are you doing here
yes yeah I'm here I walked out of my own
house I know what are you gonna do with
your in your fantasy okay
and this walk away yeah cuz you're
planting the seed like that that
remember the nwa movie where that guy's
outsider Jerry Heller uh and he goes you
live here yeah yeah it's kind of like
that it's like that's what you you don't
know where they're coming from then the
guy would probably think Steven Lee he
lives in Ohio serious but you had a
hater back in the day remember me and
Craig looked up oh yeah we took we did
we'd put it through that website yeah
he lives somewhere Whittier yeah or
something the Bob had a huge hater like
on every like on every piece of the
Facebook any social media he would just
write these [ __ ] oh and I'm so
[ __ ] with I don't know how to block
people oh no I would block up and then
he would trade another oh yeah he would
come back but then there was a website
and Craig did it yeah and we found out
the address so then I said if I know the
whole thing you know me and he typed in
the address yeah it just ended it right
there it ended it yeah it scared the
[ __ ] out of this kid yeah you have to
know where they live you know what the
thing is is you can be a cyber bully if
you want to right but they should make a
law if you're gonna do it just reveal
your real self because you get a lot of
like Trump like supporters if I go to
like Trump's Twitter yeah I read a lot
of the comments and the ones that are
supporting them are like obviously not
the person you know I mean that's fake
accounts they're fake accounts they have
two followers right and then they if
they're following 10,000 people and
they're just fake accounts a hot chick
right there's no other photo and they're
huge Trump defending him you know you
should in social media you should be
able to do whatever you want to do but
reveal your true self
[Music]